hallo leute ich es wieder einmal wanne
und ihr seht ist vielleicht vielleicht
aber auch nicht ich bin umgezogen wie
findest du meine wohnung du bist zu mir
gezogen
wieso bin ich hier und ich habe kelly
dabei weil es ist eine tradition jedes
mal wenn ich umziehe sie kelly die
wohnung als erste stimmt oder das ist
alles dieses recht billig macht
vorbehalten bis an sein lebensende ich
sehe das aber auch ein bisschen also das
ist ein bisschen wie muss ich sagen
hallo und kann ich bei mir schlafen und
kelly was macht man wenn man umzieht was
testet man als allererstes anguckt
erstmal was für lieferdienste in der
umgebung sind
und das was man zuerst macht ist
natürlich die bewertungen lesen um zu
gucken ob das restaurant auch taugt oder
nicht und durch das kommentare nach
spielen so spaß gemacht hat werden wir
jetzt lieferdienste nachspielen
lieferdienste kommentare spielen viel
spaß
pizza ohne zwiebeln bestellte pizza mit
berg von zwiebeln bekommen da war jemand
richtig traurig in welchem universums
diese pizza mit extra käse wenn das
extra käse 150 war muss die normale wohl
eher ganz ohne käse sein hat mich
wirklich geärgert weil die pizza auch
wirklich lecker war und auch schnell
gelegt wurde aber wenn ich für 150 auf
sie sind halbe salami scheibe 20 gramm
thunfisch danke nicht wieder essen mag
mir wohnen bei der carbonara die
falschen nudeln er liefert möchte eine
gutschrift des betrages von 150 pizza
war nach 100 minuten immer noch nicht da
und am telefon sehr unfreundlich müsste
dann vor lauter hunger zu burger king
fahren und das abends um 23.30 der
letzte faktor xa super fertige pizza
beck cocktails schmecken die billiger
schnaps meine frau hat sich beim ersten
schluck gleich überheben misst 50 euro
für eine kiste bier klar mein fehler
licht genau auf die preise zu schauen
trotzdem umfassend alles lecker was
heißt sein musste war es auch nur die
auszeichnung der beiden hauptgericht
aber falsch herum nun das haben wir auch
schnell herausgefunden ein stern abzug
gibt es trotzdem hier lieber keine
burger bestellen die soße von schnitzel
war einfach wasser alles gut geklappt
aber harry bus bekommen sehr freundliche
und schnelle lieferung der bürger war
ein gedicht pizza und porto apocalypse
now der typ der geliefert hat ohne worte
dreist und ein grund nicht mehr zu
bestellen weil ich nicht mehr sehen
möchte war warum pommes pizza war lecker
nur die peperoni zwar nicht klein
geschnitten lieferzeit für einen samstag
voll im limit kann ich weiter empfehlen
bekommt wir hoffen natürlich hat das
video gefallen und gibt einen extra
dicken daumen nach oben bei kelly ein
bisschen krank ist
und ich natürlich nichts sagen und
schaut auch auf jeden fall auf ihrem
kanal vorbei denn was haben wir gemacht
amazon sex toews folge war lustig
geworden er steckt den monat in dem
ontario video bekannt
ich finde ich bin das so packe das nicht
mehr sagen kann die monate der
monetarisierung nantes retikulum zehn
siegen gesehen hat so gesund so fischers
fritz frische fische frische fische
fisch frisst beschäftigte jetzt gibt's
zu aber an